comment tu fais ça ce sont les minéraux
et il y a encore mieux
c'est génial
[Musique]
attends regarde ça
je vous présente les résidents et les
mens City
les aériens ont souvent la tête dans les
nuages oh non ma nouvelle veste les
terriens sont un peu fleur bleue
les aquatiques n'hésitent jamais à se
mouiller
et nous les flamboyants votre commande
on est tout fait tout flamme
cette boutique est le rêve de notre
famille et un jour elle sera toi mais
nous cohabitons grâce à une règle d'or
le feu est l'eau ne peuvent pas être en
couple
d'où il sort en plus la tuyau
on n'est pas compatible
mon père te ferait bouillir à feu vif
mais de quel droit les gens peuvent te
dire ce que tes censé faire ou pas
suis-moi
on se demande à quoi servent ces
grillages
attends regarde ça
j'ai l'impression que tu as changé
un aquatique c'est ici que tu habites
chez l'appartement de ma mère et
on a dans une nager quelque part
j'ai essayé d'être à la hauteur de mon
père mais je ne me suis jamais demandé
ce que je rêvais de faire
tout est dans cela arrête ils sont trop
chauds ceux-là
tu vois il adore ça